even George Lucas The Mastermind behind
the Star Wars franchise wasn't so sure
the film would be a hit shortly before
Star Wars hit theaters in 1977. he
visited the set of his friend Steven
Spielberg's new movie Close Encounters
of the Third Kind Lucas was so impressed
he became convinced Close Encounters was
going to blow Star Wars away at the box
office Spielberg disagreed and offered
up a deal he would give Lucas 2.5
percent of Close Encounters box office
gross in exchange for a 2.5 percent
stake in Star Wars Lucas jumped at the
deal and by some estimates Spielberg
ended up making nearly 40 million
dollars as a result now that turned out
to be a pretty good bet